I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Oh, hey there. I need an update, a late to the party update.
We haven't discussed if anyone finished. Heated rivalry if Sam said. started heated rivalry. I'm one episode in. One episode in? It is incredible. I see the allure. Sorry I'm late. Oh, well. Also, you guys, really quickly, we have a little bit of an Earwolf family reunion. Jordan is here. Our dear Jordan Duffy, Jordan, are you watching heated rivalry? Oh, I have seen it and I've watched it over and over again. Jordan, my friend who recommended it to me has watched it three times. Yeah, I watched it like three to five times. It's insane. It's,
that good. I really love it. I finished it. I know you did because we were together on our company retreat. You guys, I have to tell you the next morning. I'm like, how'd you sleep? Jen was like, I was just going to finish one episode. I had like 20 minutes left. And then it rolled over into the next one. And then all of a sudden you watched till midnight. I stayed up till midnight because you cannot watch five and six broken up. You can't. Don't try. I'm not there yet. When it's time, make sure you leave yourself room to watch both of the kids. these episodes. Guys, it started off kind of just like super sexy time, but it ends like deeply moving. Am I right, Jordan? One hundred percent. You're right. Dear God. All right. I got to catch up. Matt,
how's it for you? Where are you at? Well, I got caught up with another late to the party sexy time thing, so I'm a bit on hold. I started watching industry. Oh, I don't know it. It's sexy? It's also super sexy time in a different way, but some of the same ways as heated rivalry. So I got a little caught up with that. I don't know anything about industry. It's about bankers in London. Sounds hot. Sounds really hot. It's very good. I recommend it. All right. Well, there's our late to the party. Why don't we kick off this episode, lady? Today's episode is really fun. We're going to give you some office news. We're going to share a little bit about this blackmail web episode featuring Creed Bratton. And of course, we've got some chit-chats. Why don't we start with the chit-chat? All right, this one's coming from
Carolyn M in Vermont. Hi, office ladies. This is Carolyn from Vermont. I don't know what cold and flu season has been like in California, but in Vermont, it's been the pits. Whenever we're sick, I like to make soup. I had the pleasure of interviewing Angela and Josh about their cookbook, and the first recipe that I made was the Italian wedding soup that's in the book. I know Angela made that for Josh when he was sick when they were first dating. and now it's our go-to recipe when my family is sick. So I was wondering what your go-to soup recipe is when you're sick. I just love this question.
I didn't pick it, you guys. I promise. Jenna picked this one. But I did love it. And here's the funny thing. I made Josh this soup. You guys, I destroyed my kitchen because I didn't know how to cook it all at the time. And I had no idea how many steps and how many ingredients.
And so my kitchen was a hot mess. But I show up to Josh's apartment with that. this big pot of soup. And he says that was the moment. He was like, oh my gosh, I have to marry this woman. She's going to make me soup for the rest of my life. And of course, like, he is the cook of the family. But I loved this question. Jenna, you love soup. Is there one that's your go-to? Well, I have a go-to soup, but it's different than the soup I like to eat when I'm sick. Oh, okay. So when I'm sick, I just want a chicken noodle. Yeah.
You know? Mm-hmm. Although Josh made me some delicious kind of a spin on a chicken noodle that was kind of a lemony chicken orzo. Oh, yeah. That you guys gave me when I was doing chemo. That's right. Oh, I loved that. That was great.
But my favorite soup to make is a soup that I made up myself. Isn't that so rewarding? Yeah. And you can make soup just like on your own? Well, I listened to this podcast by Kendra Adachi, where she's, She basically says you can make soup without a recipe, and I'm going to tell you how. Now, you wouldn't think that you could learn how to make soup without a recipe by listening to a 15-minute podcast, but you can, and I did.
She explains, like, pick your veggies, pick your protein, pick your broth, and I'm going to tell you what order to put it in, pick your aromatics, here's how you make soup. And she's like, and you can just change it up whenever you want. You don't need a recipe. She's so right. So I use a turkey sausage. I use kale, spinach, celery, carrots, onions, garlic, some oregano, a little basil, and a pinch of red pepper flakes. I'll tell you what I don't put in my soup, though. What?
Bay leaves. Do you remember those? Yeah, yeah, because I've made some soups where you add them at the end, you kind of fold them into the soup at the end. You don't like it? my mom would always make this veggie soup when I was a kid, and you're supposed to put them in, and then you leave them in for like a long period of time, I think. And then before you serve the soup,
you're supposed to take them out because they're not edible. No, you take them out. You take them out. They're just for soaking. And the flavor. Right. But my mom would always forget to take them out. Oh.
So then you'd go to take a bite of your soup, and inevitably someone would end up with the bay leaf. and you'd have to like fish it out of your mouth. This is like finding like the baby Jesus in a king cake. A little bit. Okay. But so maybe you don't mind the flavor of bay leaf. Maybe you just don't want to eat it.
Well, I got curious about bay leaves when I knew we were going to have to answer this question because I was like, what are they and what do they taste like? Because I haven't missed them. So I looked it up and it says bay leaves are from the bay laurel tree. and they add aromatic tones to the soup and that the flavor is kind of like herbal tea or a minty clove. And by the way, there are a gazillion
Reddit threads and articles dedicated to the question, do you really need a bay leaf in your soup? It's like a whole thing in the soup community. That's the internet I'm here for. Yeah. I read tons of articles about it. Yeah.
Well, I don't mind it, But, Sam, anyone else have a soup that they like? Yeah, when I'm sick, I like Campbell's Bean Soup and Sprite and Saltines. That's the perfect meal. Do you crush up the saltines in the soup? You don't. Oh, I love to crush. Do you dip them?
Nope. Oh, on the side. Sam. I know. I'm wild. Gosh, I love a salty cracker crushed up in a soup. Crushed in it. Well, you know, you crack it.
I don't want to stick the whole square in my soup. I break it up. I only like those little oyster round things in a clam chowder. I get so excited if I'm at dinner with someone and they get clam chowder and they don't want those, I'm like, you're going to eat those? Yeah. Pass them over here. Those are great.
Great. Jordan. I also like a chicken noodle, but in mixture, I do crunch up the crackers and put them in because they like thicken up the soup. Yes, they do, Jordan. Yes, they do. Mm-hmm. I see you.
Matt, you want to weigh in on the soups? I do. I'm a big Mexican soup guy. So Pesole is my go-to and sick. I make it with chicken. Are you all familiar with Pesole? No, is it spicy? Maybe a little bit, but it's with like tomatoos and meat.
It's usually with pork, but I make it with chicken. And then you put hominy in, which is like the puffed corn, which is rare, but really featured in this dish. And it just, it's amazing. It's like a soup that has that magic in it. That sounds great. My favorite is the Josh's chicken. chicken lemon orzo soup. So you know what, guys, I'm going to share in our stories. Everyone send me
their link for their soups. And anyone listening who loves the soup, it'll be in our Insta stories. And I'll share Kendra's episode where she talks about soup. Yeah, because then you can make any soup you want. That's right. All right. Well, that was fun. Why don't we take a break? And then when we get back, we're going to discuss some office news and blackmail. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, we are going to take a moment to celebrate women and all that they carry at work, in relationships, and families, and in the many roles they hold every single day. And we need to remind ourselves about how much we matter and that therapy offers a space for us to take care of ourselves in the way we deserve.
Therapy can also be a place to set boundaries and build confidence. Just take care of your own well-being for a change. Better help makes therapy accessible and flexible. Their therapists are fully licensed in the U.S. and follow a strict code of conduct. With over 30,000 therapists BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, and it works. With an average rating of 4.9 out of 5 for a live session based on over 1.7 million client reviews. Your emotional well-being matters. Find support and feel lighter in therapy. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies.
That's better. H-E-L-P.com slash office. ladies. Hey guys, Willie Geist here reminding you to check out the Sunday Sit Down podcast. On this week's episode, I get together with music superstar Charlie Puth to talk about his nailing the national anthem at this year's Super Bowl and the inspiration for his new album drawn from a line about him in a recent Taylor Swift song. You can get our conversation now for free wherever you download your podcasts. Right. We are back. And, you know, we've been breaking. breaking down the paper for the last nine weeks, and we wanted to come back and hit you with some office news. Because a lot has happened in the universe of the office. We have a lot to share.
So let's start things off with a conversation about the fact that the season nine superfan episodes are out. Yes, Dave Rogers has finished them. He's finished super fans of the whole series. Bless his heart. That was a lot of work. That was a lot of work. I know. He said he spent his whole summer on it. Yeah. Well, I want to tell you guys how to find them because Dave worked so hard and he did a fantastic job. They're over on Peacock, but I want to tell you how they're labeled. They made this whole graphic. It says, the office superfan episodes. And then in like huge letters, it says, complete collection. Because they're done. Because they're done. Mm-hmm. Well, Dave sent me a list of highlights of the new stuff they added. And it's pretty
great. I'm going to just tell you a few. In episode, here comes trouble. Andy sings his signature song, Faith at the end. Get out. Yeah. So you can see that. In the target, they added back that deleted scene of Thanksgiving at the office. Oh, wow. So officially there is an office Thanksgiving moment. Now there is. He said there's also some great ads with Jim and Phyllis and Stanley going to lunch, and at the restaurant, and there's a lot more of Angela and Trevor talking in the van. He said there's also a new talking head from Pam where she talks about taking risks and wakeboarding, which I love, he said. I want to see that.
I know. I don't even remember doing a talking head about wakeboarding. Pam wakeboards? Well, I don't know. I haven't gone in to look at the details. We'll have to dig into it. Okay. Also, in episode.
episode 12, there is a new cold open that is a deleted scene where everyone is absorbed in their phones. I remember shooting that. I do too. And I know they wrote that because we all used to come to set around this time and we were all absorbed in our phones. And I felt like it was a little like subtle. Like a dig. Yeah. Like they were making fun of us. Well, come on. We're old. We all like over one summer switch from flip phones. Yep. To like blackberries. And then we finally got those like the very first version of a smartphone. Yes. And we were like little kids. I was Blackberry for a long time. Same. I was very resistant to changing because I liked that the keys actually clicked. Me too. Like you felt the resistance when you touched them. I still hate the like typing on my iPhone.
Do you have the setting where it clicks so you hear it? No. No. Do you? I used to, but it drove everyone crazy. around. But I think it's because it's a holdover from the Blackberry. I liked the little click, the little sound. So my problem is two things. When I go to hit the letter N, sometimes I hit the space bar instead, and it bothers me. Or sometimes when I mean to hit the space bar, I accidentally hit the period. And that really messes me up because when I'm trying to Google something or search for something, if I put a period instead of a space, it thinks I want to go to a website and then it tells me that you're making no sense, lady.
Yeah. So I still don't like it. I wish the period was somewhere else. I don't know. Can you all move the period? I'd appreciate it. How about that for an update that I actually want? You know what update I didn't need is making my screen look like glass.
Oh, yeah. I don't want to look at glass. I also don't like the photo update, like where your photos are kept. It's all different. I don't like it. Sam Jordan are nodding. They're nodding. What's happening?
No, I was nodding with furious agreement. Oh, thank you. It's my phone's, I hate it now. Yeah, I hate it. Yeah. I do remember I have such a strong visual lady of being on set with you. And we would want to like, oh, should we answer this email or something? Like maybe we needed to respond to something.
And you'd be like, I'll do it. And you are the fastest thumb typeer in the world. Wow. You just won that award. There's your Dundee. Okay, I have a few more things to share about the superfan episodes. Dave said episode Vandalism has a ton of great ads throughout, especially with Pam Dwight and Clark in the warehouse.
He said there is also just more Nate overall, including an ad lib that led to the famous blooper. Frank did it, did it? Yeah. Here is a really good one, though. Episode 17, more Bob Odenkirk. Really? He said there's extra scenes of me and Bob, and they're really great.
And finally, he said the finale has a lot more cool moments, including just some Easter eggs for us of other people who were part of the show. And he said it's really fun to see, and maybe fans will also appreciate them, especially now that they know, like, a lot of people's names. Yeah. and what their jobs were. Now you can put a face to the name. Dave, I love this list.
It's making me all nostalgic. I know. To like go back and rewatch. Well, thank you, Dave Rogers, for all of the time you put into these superfan episodes. I really now have a few I want to go back and watch. For sure. I have to watch Andy Sing Faith.
Yeah. That's my number one, I think. All right. Well, now we have some news from our office universe. This Friday, on March 20th, Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stepnitsky's new show is coming out. You remember these guys. They wrote on the office for many, many years. They wrote dinner party. They wrote dinner party. They also played Leo and Gino. Yes. They've been on the podcast. Well, you might remember a few years ago,
they had that amazing show, jury duty. It was a fake documentary about a trial where everybody was an actor except one person was real. Right. And he wasn't in on it. Everyone else was in on it. He thought it was a real trial happening. Yes. It was amazing.
Critically acclaimed. Well, they have a season two and a new concept, and it is absolutely brilliant. It's brilliant. Lee sent Jen and I, the trailer, and it is hilarious. I'm already hooked. It's called Company Retreat, and the new premise is that cameras are following this newly hired employee at a small business. And shortly after he gets hired, the whole company is going to go on a company retreat. Yes. And everyone at the business is an actor except for the new employee.
You guys, I wrote Lee and I was like, this is brilliant. I feel like this is what it would be like if you could go be transported into an episode of the office. Exactly. Like if you were the new employee and you had to go to beach games. Yes, exactly. And that's like part of your first week of work. But one of the brilliant things about it is the owner of the business is about to turn the business over to his son. And the son is just like full hot nepo baby.
Yes. Hot mess. Hilarious. But then as the company retreat unfolds, you see all the different personalities of the coworkers because they have to do these ridiculous exercises. like walk on the hot coals, that type of stuff, right? Yes. Not to go back to beach games, but I couldn't help but think of that episode as I watched the trailer.
I'm sure it's going to be amazing. Jury Duty was amazing. No, it's going to be a big hit. I can't wait to watch it. So we just want to wish them. Congratulations. Everybody, you can check it out. The first three episodes debut this Friday, March 20th on Prime Video.
Congrats, Lee and Jean. We love you guys. Well, not on the same level, but Jenna and I actually just had art. very own company retreat. We did. It was a two-person company retreat. It was just me and Jenna, we went to a hotel about, I don't know, like 40 minutes away. Yep. And we brought our laptops and we just worked and worked office ladies. And it was so fun because we also have BFF time. Yeah. Mixed in with all that. And we have decided a bunch of fun stuff. But what I want to share today, which is we want to really start hearing from you guys during our second
drinks. Yeah. You know, so many of you write in and you will tell us a favorite moment, a favorite scene, and we thought what a better way to feature those than in our second drinks. We're going to call them fan favorite moments. We'll put up some folders as our episodes roll out. Please write in and tell us your favorite scene from these upcoming episodes. So be on the lookout. We're going to give you prompts in our Insta stories for whatever episodes are coming out, but we would love to hear your favorite scenes and we're going to talk about them. You know, ladies, we've just been incorporating all these ways that we get to hear from people now with the fan chit-chats and the around-the-towns. And I really like it. I feel like it was really inspired from your trip to the office convention when we got to hear all the audio from people.
And when I was recording people at the stage door in Chicago. And we talked about it. We were like, we like this. Yes. And then I think the other thing that happened is we found out that we could get audio clips on our website. Yes, that you can upload them. Yeah, that was a game changer. Shout out to Squarespace. Sorry, it took us so long, you guys, to get caught up with that technology, but we really love hearing from you and can't wait to hear your favorite moments from upcoming second drinks.
We also have a couple of social media updates for you. First of all, I want you to know that I have updated our links in bio. Way to go. On Instagram. Angela, you handle all the posting, but my job is. the links in bio. So I'm going to do better, everybody. These links will be more extensive and take you places you want to go. So I just want to put that out there. Very proud of you. Thank you. And the other thing we're excited to share with you is that we have partnered again with Cartooner
Radio. You know, they do amazing animation of podcasts. And they are going to do the first six episodes from season one of our rewatch of the office. And they're going to do sort of like the high lights of things that we talked about. And they're so fun. They're up on our YouTube page, our Office Ladies YouTube page, and you can watch them. And we hope you like them. Yeah, the cool thing about it is that we were able to add our personal photos. So it's like a 10-minute highlight of each episode. But like, for example, in the pilot, we flash up all of our personal photos from the pilot. And Angela, I have to share something. So when we were looking for what to share visually from Diversity Day. We talk a little bit about like how great the script
was and how I still have my script. And so I thought, oh, I know, I'll take a picture of my script from Diversity Day so we can flash it up in this video. Right. So I went digging for it. And first of all, my script from Diversity Day is on blue paper. Oh, so that was the second version. Yes, I was going to explain, that's how they would distinguish the different drafts of a script. So first, they would give it to us on white paper. And then they would either give you a whole new printout on blue paper or if there were just a few changes, they'd just give you blue pages. Right. And then it was your job to go in and take out the white page and put in the blue page for the rewrite. And then the third draft would be pink pages. And then I think it was like yellow, green. And then I feel like it went back to white.
No, I think every once while we got to orange, but that was very rare. Yeah. And those were usually loose pages. Yes. They weren't the whole script. But sometimes by the end of the week, you'd have like this multi-colored script. Well, anyway, this script was all blue. So I guess they did one big rewrite and they printed it out on blue.
I don't have any other color pages. However, at the very end of my script, I have five white pages. You guys, I want you to know Jenna brought. her script in. She's holding it. I'm looking at it. And what did you write on the front of it? Did you write Pam? Pam. I wrote Pam. So everyone knows that's your script. That's so cute. Well, that was a thing back then. Like, if you didn't put your name on it, anyone might pick it up. It's true. Well, I was like, what are the white pages at the end? Do you know what it is, lady?
No, what is it? It's my Pam document. I printed it out. I three-hole punched it. and I attached it to the back of my script. And I remember I did that for season one of the office. Lady, your theater nerd heart is so wonderful. And I'm so excited I found this because I couldn't find it on my computer. So this is now the only copy I have is this hard copy that I printed and attached to the back of my Diversity Day script. And I have to read you something from it. I want to hear all of it.
I mean, I wish I had this for all about Pam Beasley. Oh. But here we go. I have this section where I'm really trying to figure out Pam and Roy's relationship. And so I wrote this prompt, what was your biggest fight? I wrote, our biggest fight ever was the time that I told him that if I found out that he committed a murder, that I would turn him into the police. Like, if they didn't know who did it and he wasn't. planning to turn himself in. He got really, really mad and said that families are supposed to
protect each other. And I said, yeah, but not from murder. He said, what if he was really, really sorry? And I could tell that he would never murder someone again. I don't know. I still think I'd probably turn him in. That's amazing. Yeah. That's amazing. And it's such like one of those hypothetical bullshit things that you get in a fight about because the real things aren't working. Yeah. So you don't talk about the real things and then you have all of this pent up stuff about a hypothetical. Well, I think it kind of touched on a type of disconnect in their like fundamental values, you know? Yeah. Like Roy values family loyalty over everything. And Pam sort of is a rule follower.
And feels like she has a sort of moral obligation to the world that sometimes could supersede the family. Yes. I was like, that's really interesting. I also wrote, I used to be an illustrator, but Roy told me it was time for us to get regular jobs. I used to just be a receptionist on the side while I drew and tried to get work as an illustrator. I'm artistic, but I've given it up to have a more stable life and job. That is great. Because for me, that fills in that question of like, why is Pam there? Why is she the receptionist? Why does she seem so beat down in this job on top of everything else?
It seems like a real step back for her, just being there. Yeah. I felt like I needed to answer those questions for myself when I started the job. Theater students out there. How about that background work, building your character, things people don't ever see. It's true. Well, thank you very much to Cartuna for asking us to dig around in our personal photos because now I have my Pam document back. And you guys, I'll share in our stories where you can find our animated highlights of the first six episodes of Office Ladies. And you can also find
them at the link in bio. Oh, yes, because Jenna's updated the link in bio. Yes, I have. All right, well, Angela, now I'm very excited. I'm going to turn it over to you. You watch the webisode blackmail. Yes, I did, and it is so delicious. It features Creed. First of all, I want you guys to know where you can find these. All of the webisodes are on Peacock, but they're labeled a little different. You have to go to the tile that says the office, like the original office, not the superfan versions. And then under that, you have to click on a little tab that says collections. And then under that, scroll down, and there's a little thing that says digital series. I don't want to get in their business, but I guess I do.
Why are you making it so hard to find these? Yeah, you do have to dig. And also, we always called them webisodes. So I guess they call them digital series. But that's where they live and there's a bunch of them and they're fantastic. And today I want to highlight blackmail. It is a series of four, around two-minute clips and you just watch them all in a row. clip one reveals Creed has decided to blackmail his co-workers. The first person he's going to
try to blackmail is Oscar. So the opening scene is Oscar watching a video on a laptop of Creed, and then Creed walks in behind him in real time. It's all in the conference room. I want you guys to hear it. If you're watching this video, you've been a very naughty person. I have learned some of your deepest, darkest secrets. And with this not... I have the ability to ruin your world. But it needn't come to that. It's possible I could forget a thing or two. If you're willing to compensate me, I'm 100% serious.
Pay me now, or I will share this with the world. Are my eyes blue? Are you trying to blackmail me? Blackmail is an ugly word. I prefer extortion. Why are you doing this? How much will you pay me to find out? Creed, this is low. Easy on the sass.
We're just two amigos having a guess. two amigos having a conversation, Comprehended. All right. Let's switch back to English for a second. Just spit it out. What do you have on me? So, first of all,
Creed saying easy on the SaaS made my whole day. But what we find out that Creed has on Oscar is a video of Oscar getting picked up from work by his boyfriend. It's so uninteresting.
It's so normal. And Oscar just dismisses it and leaves. So now Creed has to move on to someone else. Well, everybody already knows about Oscar and Gill. I mean, remember after Gay Witch Hunt, they get to leave on like a 12-week vacation paid for by the company. Right.
So this isn't news, Creed. Exactly. And Oscar just dismisses it. Yeah. So now he's got to move on to Andy. And he hands Andy this green envelope. Andy takes a look inside and completely is thrown. He is shaken by whatever is inside this green envelope.
That is sort of the cliffhanger that takes you to clip two. Clip two starts with Andy freaking out. Creed has given him an ultimatum, and he clearly has some good dirt on him. But Andy says, I don't know what to do yet. And then we learn a tough decision that Andy had to make in the past. Let's hear it. I'm freaking out. And I haven't freaked out about a decision like this since I had to choose between here comes treble.
travel in paradise, the troubleshooters, and the Finger Lake Maestro's. That was his decision. He had to pick between these acapella groups. And I just think about our writers sitting there pitching different names for acapella groups, and they're all so amazing. You know they spent way too many hours on those name pitches. Oh, yeah. I bet there's a ton more that we didn't even get to hear. So anyway, Crete is going to keep pressuring Andy, and then Andy just decides he's got to take matter of. into his own hands, and he is going to make this huge announcement to the bullpen about what Creed has on him. Any guesses, lady? I can't think of anything. I was not prepared for this.
He lifts up his shirt to show everyone he has a tattoo on his lower back. And it looks like it's written in sort of a different language. And he shares that it means nard dog. Kelly starts teasing him, says he has a tramp stamp. And Andy says he doesn't regret it, but he is how he has. having it lasered off. So lady, Andy, this is his other tattoo? Because he had Nard Dog. Well, he gets Nard Dog. Exactly. So is this webisode between now and when he gets Nard Dog? It's got to be, but it's just hilarious to me that Andy has such mishaps with tattoos. Well, this is his snip, snap, snip, snip moment then. He had a Nard Dog tattoo that he got lasered off and then he went and got another nard dog tattoo. Exactly. But remember that trend where people
would get different sayings or messages in like a different language? I don't know the tattoo trends. What? Sam, are you there? This was, I remember in my improv days, there would be like some dude with like some type of character type writing on their arm and it would mean like truth. That and tribal tattoo goes in and out of popularity every decade. Yeah. Yeah. Do you remember the armband? tattoo that Pamela Anderson got, the barbed wire. Yes. Those are in style again, by the way. Are they back?
Yep. I always liked those. That and tramp stamps are officially back. Tramp stamps are back. Well, Andy had one in a language. She wasn't really sure what it was, but it said Nard Dog. That's the thing. I always was like, if it's not the language you speak and you don't speak that language,
how do you know? How do you know what's getting tattooed on you? Yep. You got to really trust your tattoo artist. Yeah, you do. You guys, I have a story of a famous guy. I'm not going to say who it is. Oh, come on.
But only because he would tell this story. If we had him on our podcast, he would tell this story. Okay. But I was working on a project with him, and he wanted to get a tattoo. And he came to set, and he was, like, talking about what he wanted. And it was, like, a nautical thing. And he had other tattoos. So this wasn't his first.
And he was kind of going over it. And then eventually he got it. And he came and he showed it to us. And it was nothing at all like what he had kind of been describing to us that he wanted. And it wasn't great. I'm going to also say like it's not that the tattoo work wasn't great, but the design. Where on his body was it? God, I think it was like on his biceps.
Okay, good. Wait, Sam, why is that okay, good? I wanted to be visible and prominent. Visible and prominent. So, yeah, it was. Like, short-sleevee shirt. Good. Here it is.
Yep. Oh, my gosh. And we're all looking at it and none of us know how to react. And so we're all kind of like, huh? And he goes, I know. I know. And we're like, it's just different than what you said. He goes, I know.
When I got there and he showed me the drawing, I didn't like it. What? But I felt bad, so I just let him do it. Tattooed on my body forever? Yeah. Because you felt bad? Because he was like, he didn't want. He didn't want to speak up.
Yeah. He just, like, didn't want to disappoint the tattoo artist? Yeah. And then we were like, dude, It's on you forever. Yeah, you got to push back a little. And he was like, I know, I really regret not saying something. Oh, my gosh.
What? And then we just teased him incessantly about it. I wonder if he ever got it lasered off. I don't think so. Did he pull an Andy? I couldn't ask him, I guess, but maybe he likes it now. I mean, maybe it grew on him. But you guys, it looks like something.
like a nautical logo on the menu of a fish restaurant. That's... That's sharkies in Redondo Beach. Something like that. Yeah. Something like that. Just super basic. Sure.
I don't know how long it's been since you've spoken to this person, but if you did out of nowhere, let's say, text him and say, hey, remember that random nautical tattoo you got? Did you have it lasered off? I'll do it. Would you think it's odd and would he respond? I'll ask him. Oh my God, she's texting right now.
I mean, this is super round. Let's see, the last time we texted was last October. Oh, that's not bad. Yeah. Okay. What is Jordan laughing about? I can hear Jordan laughing. I just said I wanted to be like Ben Affleck or somebody with that.
Does Ben Affleck still have that giant? Yes, on his back. It's real, right? It's a Phoenix, yeah, and it's bad. Nope. It's not what? I always thought that was for a movie. No, it's real.
And it is on there full time. And it's full color. Wow. And so, Sam, you've had tattoos. Like full color. That's a multi. That's multiple sessions. Yeah.
Wow. And multiple thousands of dollars. Do you have any tattoos that you have soured on since you got them, Sam? Yes. I have the word truth written in Latin on my left arm. Oh my God. No, you don't. Sam, I'm telling you.
I'm telling you right now, there was a guy in my improv days that had truth on his forearm, written in like Mandarin. Well, this is an old thing. It's just, they just don't like the placement of it. It's blocking other bigger tattoos. Okay. That's amazing. Well, while we wait for Jenna's mysterious, famous person with the lame nautical
tattoo to get back to us, we are going to move on now to clip three of the Blackmail Webisode series. Now Creed, Andy's sort of big announcement worked. Creed has to move on to someone else, and it's Kelly. He hands Kelly. green envelope. Kelly looks inside and it's a picture of her kissing a girl. She's completely unfazed. She's like, Creed, this is my MySpace profile picture. And she really loves the attention that's getting her. I have to give a shout out right here to the fellows on how we made your mother
because they shared with us that they love our old tech callouts during our rewatch of the office. and they have added one. They have one called Old Ref, which is like an old reference. And I think MySpace is both Old Tech and Old Ref. Yep. So Creed is going to try again with Kelly because he's desperate now. And he's like, all right, fine, I've got something else on you. And we find out that Kelly skipped work to go to a Jonas Brothers concert.
Oh. And then Kelly Caves. She's like, ugh. And Creed lists off his demands. Let's hear them. And if you want me to be silent, I'm going to need a little something from you. Creed, I cannot lose my job. I have so much credit. I want a helicopter.
I can't afford that. Well, then, I want commodities. I want gold, oil, political capital, four-leaf clovers, bones, information, uranium. Do you mean information like facts? No, like gossip. What do you want to know? I mean, Kelly can play ball on gossip. Yeah, well, now he can use.
use what she tells him to blackmail more people. Exactly. This cuts immediately to Creed, walking through the whole bullpen, passing out green envelopes left and right. He gives one to Angela. Then he gives one to Meredith. Meredith opens hers and says, who's Pastor Jim? And then Creed's like, oh, wait a second. And he grabs that one and hands it to Angela, and Angela's all flushed. I know. Did Angela hook up with Pastor Jim? We don't know. But that's as far as that moment goes, because then Oscar's like, wait, we've got to take care of this. Next clip is clip four. So Oscar has dug up a bunch of stuff on Creed, and they all confront him with it in the conference room. There's like a list of all sorts of stuff. Two that stood out for me was that Creed introduced
the walking snakehead fish to the North American ecosystem. And he has it on good authority that Creed throws raves in the warehouse and is known by party goers as Papa Smurf. What does that mean, Sam, by the way, if you're known as Papa Smurf at a rave? I don't know. I thought maybe it meant something. No. It could mean that you're like you give people like... In all my years of going to raves and doing drugs, I've never been labeled Papa Smurf.
I didn't think you had been labeled, but I didn't know if at a rave. Listen, all I know about raves is from John Wick movies. That's all you need to know. That's all that's going on. It's where assassins go to like. Like run through the crowd. Yeah. Yeah.
Anyway, ultimately, Andy is like, what are we doing? You guys, they look and see that the amount of money Crete is blackmailing them for. Any guesses? What? No. Six dollars. What does he want to get? Wait, wait.
He says $6 are the equivalent in postage stamps or canned goods. And Andy's like, this just kind of makes me feel bad. He clearly needs the $6. So they all just cave in and they give Creed the money. It ends with Creed super happy. He's at his laptop. And there's an image on his computer. It's a toy helicopter.
But Creed clearly thinks it's a real helicopter. And he takes his $6 and, you guys, he shoves it into the floppy disk feet. Like he thinks it's going to spit out the toy. Like a vending machine. Yes. And he explains that he's so excited. He's going to fly his new helicopter to Brazil to see the world's largest library. Oh.
And that is the end of blackmail. There are some great scenes that I didn't even get into because some of them are visuals. They're so funny. You guys, I really recommend this one. It's a fun watch. Well, that was delightful, Angela. Thank you for breaking that down for us. I just thought it was so fun.
I loved filming these webisodes, and it was always just a skeleton crew and a group of us on the weekends, and we got to just play around. So it kind of brought me down memory lane. Well, I haven't heard back from my famous friend. So why don't we take a break? When we come back, we've got around the town and our office question of the week and maybe also an answer about this tattoo. We are back. Still no news from my friend, everybody.
Sorry to leave you hanging. But now it's time for... Our first bit of news is from Michelle G in Stratford, Ontario, Canada. Michelle wants us to know, Stratford has a lot going on this year. We have been named a top 10 list of places in Canada to visit. We have our chef school running fun courses for anyone to attend. Our theater is in its 73rd year. We have a chocolate tour, a baking.
Aitin and Ail Tour and Audio Walking Tours. We are also dealing with the most snow that we have had in years. Well, Michelle, I'm jealous of all your snow. The skiers in my family have been chasing snow. It's not in any of the usual places this year. So I guess it's come to you. Well, I just want to go to the walking tours. I mean, a bacon and ale tour? Bacon and ale. Chocolate tour? Mm-hmm. Yes, please.
I know. All right. Our next around the town is from Becca B. Becca says, every year around National Golden Retriever Day, Golden Colorado hosts an event called Goldens and Golden. Thousands, and she put that in all caps, thousands of golden retrievers or impostors and their owners gathered to celebrate all of the good boys. Isn't that adorable? Golden Retriever Day? Yes. Oh my gosh. I have actually seen on Instagram like these golden retriever gatherings where people all get together with their golden retrievers. I know there's several different dog breeds that do this, but it's pretty freaking adorable. All right. I looked this up. The article says over 5,500 in golden retrievers gathered in Golden Colorado on February 7th to enjoy the annual Goldens and Golden celebration. Wow.
I want to go! My friend has a golden retriever, and whenever, like, there's a group of them, like, we'll go on a hike, and then they all, like, say hi to each other. I don't know. It's just so cute, you guys. It looks like they smile. Lady, you have to post about this because I'm looking at this article, and the photos are incredible. Yeah, I've seen on Instagram.
It's just amazing. We'll share in our stories. It's way bigger than you could even imagine. I mean, I know we're throwing out numbers, but when you see everybody together, you're like, holy moly. All right. Well, our last bit of Around the Town comes from Natalie D in Kansas City, who said, I have been competitive bowling since I was 13 years old.
Natalie is now 28 and finally got her first 300 perfect game last week. Natalie, congratulations. Thanks to the office ladies for providing entertainment on long car rides to tournaments. That is a big deal. That is a big accomplishment. 300. My grandpa was a bowler, and I remember when he got his 300 game. It was huge.
It was like such a big deal. That is, how many? 12 strikes in a row? Because the 10th frame is three? Yeah, I think so. Wow. Well done. That is amazing. Natalie, my bowling is I either get up there and I just roll the slowest moving ball that hits the pins and it's like phe, and I get a strike and everyone's like, what just happened? Or I got her ball it. Those are the only two. That's my skill set. That's incredible. I know. It's pretty amazing. Sign me up for your team. All right. Up next, everybody, is our office. question of the week. This comes from Nadia H in Michigan. Nadia says, hello, office ladies. I have been
wanting to write you all for over a year now, and I am beyond excited that I am now caught up with the podcast episodes and can share how much you two mean to me. The office is my favorite show. I own all of the DVD box sets, tons of merch, and I even have an office comforter that I use every night. You two are truly some of the most special people in the world, and thank you so much for all the hard work, that you put into the Office Ladies franchise. Aw, that's so sweet. Nadia goes on to say, I am a neurodivergent individual who lives in a world that is not always friendly or accepting of people like me. This can be very hard and overwhelming at times, but whenever I listen to your podcast, I feel so heard, seen, and just at peace. I could go on for ages about how much YouTube
mean to me, but in summary, I just want you to know how much I love you both. And the Nadia sent in a bunch of questions, and one of the ones we want to answer today is, do you guys ever feel weird seeing your face on merchandise or wallpapers? And she also said, P.S. Angela, I love your diary. It's one of my favorite things ever. Nadia, first of all, we just want to say thank you for all those kind words. Yes. I can't even tell you what it means to me that the podcast brings you peace and comfort. Yeah. And that you feel seen and. heard and we love doing this podcast and we really love our office ladies family. So thank you so
much for being part of it. And also, yes, it is weird seeing my face on merchandise and wallpapers. I'm not sure I've ever gotten used to it. It's just weird and it's, it pops up in the most random places. I think I've shared this before. One time my sister Janet texted me and she was at T.J. Max. And she said, and your face is on a shot glass. Yeah. Yeah, it is just really wild and it's has just kept going all these years. Well, did you hear now they're turning the office characters into Fortnite skins? I did hear this.
My sons told me. Well, Dwight and Michael are out. Jim and Pam are coming out. I don't know if they're going to do more. And, you know, something I want to let everyone know is that I found this out in the news. Like, nobody asked me. I didn't have to give permission. I don't get paid anything for it.
Well, none of us do. No. The whole entire, whatever, whoever they feature anywhere doing stuff, we don't get paid for it. No, which is also weird. Yeah. Because you just feel like your face is everywhere. But I was like, really, I don't get anything for my face as a fortnight skin. And I guess it's quote unquote, Pam.
It's not me. But I'm like, but just because it's my face. in a pink sweater. Like, so anytime you take my face and put it in a pink sweater, it's not me, it's Pam, and then I don't get anything for it. NBC gets the money. I find that weird. I'm sorry, I find it weird. Yeah.
I don't understand why we don't get a cut of that. It is weird. It's just weird every time. Well, you know, it's like sometimes it's just so clearly our face, you know? It's like so like. It's literally a picture of us. Yeah. But anyway, Nadia, it is kind of odd.
It is. And I think what's always interesting to me is the different ways they find to put our faces on things. Like this Fortnite skins and a shot glass or a bath towel. Do either of you remember the first thing that you saw your face on? Like when the office, you know, like season one, season two, like when merch started rolling out? Oh, gosh. that's a good question. I know that the NBC store in New York
had like a Jim and Pam mug or something. And it was around Valentine's Day. And I remember John and I went to New York and we did like a little press thing and we were in the NBC store. And I was like, oh my gosh, John, we're on this mug. Yeah. So maybe that was the first time I saw my son.
as merch. Okay. Yeah, I think for me, it was NBC put out these little Valentine's cards. Oh, okay. And it had Dwight and Angela. It had the ladies all around Michael Scott. He's holding up a heart. Yeah.
And there were these little Valentine's cards you could buy. And I was so tickled by it. I really was just so delighted. And I think the thing, Nadia, I would want you to know, it's like, I love fans that find creative ways to recreate our characters. I love all the fan art so much. And I think sometimes, though, you feel like you're part of some big corporate machine when it's like Fortnite skins. It's different.
It's a little different, you know? Yeah. But I love fans' interpretations of the characters on the show. And I love it when people make us stuff and send it to us. It's really cool. But when you're out just walking around somewhere and your face is on like a T.J. Max shot blast. You're like, wait, how did that happen? I think that's a good point, Angela.
I am here for every Etsy shop where a fan has interpreted our characters and made some super cool thing. Yeah. And usually that stuff is way cooler, too. Yeah. I think you're right. It's like when the big mega corporation is getting a bunch of money because they put your face on something and then it's just another big mega corporation splitting all the funds. Like, I'd much rather some, like, cool Etsy artist get some Moolah. Yeah.
You know what I'm saying? Absolutely. Yeah. So Etsy, folks, we're here for you. Keep it up. Yeah. All right. Well, listen, that's all we've got, except we have one more thing.
Did the anonymous celebrity with the lame nautical tattoo get back to you? I've seen you texting over there. He did. He did. And first of all, he wrote, yes. I still have it. Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha. And then he said, the tattoo artist was so handsome and cool.
I didn't want to disappoint him. And then he said I could reveal who he is, and he sent me in some audio. No way. Oh, my gosh. Exclusive celebrity with lame nautical tattoo is Oliver Hudson. Oliver. I would never have guessed. Here we go.
So I wanted to get a tattoo for my kids for years and didn't really know what it was. I knew I wanted something nautical because of my love for the ocean. I wanted something a little different, something cool, not your standard old school anchor. And I went to this guy, I don't say his name, because I don't want to disson. He's an incredible artist. Like, there's no doubt it just wasn't his forte, I guess. Anyway, I went there. he put the stencil on me that he sort of came up with.
And it just, well, I wasn't really feeling it, but he was so cool and extremely handsome and all tatted up that I felt like insecure about making any changes. And I said, well, what if we did this? And he did something else and put another stencil on. I was like, yeah, even though I was like, oh, my God. No. And then I get on the table.
Four hours later, I have it on my arm. And it looks like a chandelier. It doesn't look like an anchor. It looks like a grand chandelier in a beautiful ballroom. But it's on me forever now. And I was depressed for a long time. And now I only get depressed every once in a while. He's probably like, thanks for bringing it back up.
You guys, I'm so glad he said that in, Because I just need you to know that is the delight that it is to work with Oliver Hudson. If you just want to have the best, most fun project, you want to hire Oliver Hudson. And he's so talented, too. Like, he's so funny. He's so good with drama. I adore him so much. And you should share you guys work together on splitting up together.
Yes, for two seasons of a TV show. Yeah. And we ended her show on like this giant cliffhanger because we got canceled. We had this big cliffhanger. We were all sure we were going to get to season three and then they canceled us. And it was such a bummer. I worked on that with Bobby Lee. Yeah. Yeah. Great group. Oliver, thank you so much. I really need to see a picture now. I don't know if he'd be up for sending us a picture, but chandelier is not the image I had in my head this whole time. I know. Maybe I didn't describe it very well. My memory. You described it perfectly.
Did I? Yeah. Okay. Oh my gosh, Oliver, thank you. And you know what? You got to come. You got to come hang with us on office ladies. He really does. It would be the absolute best time. Well, you guys, that was Office News and Blackmail. We hope you enjoyed it. Yeah. Check out the link and bio for all kinds of cool stuff. Oh, here it is. I'm sorry. He just sent it. He just sent it. I want to see it. He just sent a photo. I need to see it. I'm sorry. Turn it around. Sam Jordan. It's worse than I remember. I'm sorry.
Do you see it? I do. It's like multiple anchors. It's multiple anchors hanging. It's like adorned with jewels. It's like multiple anchors hanging off an anchor with like also the letter H. Well, because he has three kids. It's like he went to a very fancy Navy.
So I think it's three anchors. It's so large, you guys. So much of his arms. Can I see? Oh my God, it's enormous. It's his whole bicep. And I like if you zoom in, he's grimacing just a bit. Oh, Oliver, I love you so much. I love you so much. I want to say a quick thank you to Jordan Duffy for coming in today.
She is going to be here whenever Sam has to travel or go out of town. Jordan, thanks so much. It was great to see you. It was so great seeing you guys too. I'm so happy to be helping out when I can. Yay! Yay! All right, everyone. We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. You know, a lot of times you get ads that are just not meant for you. You're like, why am I getting this? And a lot of times those business-to-business marketing ads get wasted on the wrong people.
Well, LinkedIn doesn't want to be one of those people that's sending out an ad that's not targeted, that's not intended. They have grown a network of over one billion professionals and 130 million decision makers, and that is where it stands apart from other ad buys. First of all, you can target your buyers by job title, industry, company, role, seniority, skills, and company revenue. So you can stop wasting budget on the wrong. wrong audience. If you want to reach the right professionals, use LinkedIn ads. It's why LinkedIn ads generate the highest business-to-business ROAS of all online ad networks, seriously all of them. Spend $250 on your first campaign on LinkedIn ads and get a free $250 credit for the next one.
Just go to LinkedIn.com slash office. That's LinkedIn.com slash office. Terms and conditions apply. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.